[Music]
hey roblo my name is regina and i'm from
saratoga new york
and i adore you first of all in
everything you've ever done
i am curious i know you love animals and
dogs especially and
was wondering about champion from parks
and rec whose dog was that
or is that if he's still alive and i
hope he is and um
it looked like you really got along
really well with him
do you still see champion
thanks rob
love to you and your family
bye-bye
oh thanks regina oh it's great to hear
from you thanks for calling in
yes it was obvious wasn't it how much i
love champion
i loved that dog so much first i love
animals and i love dogs anyway but
champion was really really special and
one of my great memories of doing parks
and recreation is
the scene where um my character chris
traeger is being emotional i think he's
crying lying on a bed and champion is
just licking his face
and it's making chris laugh um and we
had to put you know the old trick you
put a little bit of peanut butter on
your face and the dog wants to lick it
off champion was so sweet but champion
passed away last year sadly enough
um and he was a trained professional
actor
he was a rescue
that they trained um
and
i don't remember if
champion was written as a three-legged
dog
and then they found a three-legged dog
or the dog that they brought to play
champion hit who showed up in ether i
don't remember the
the genesis of it
um
but i particularly love a i did a
talking head in parks and rec with
champion
and
in a kennedy voice i say
each bean i three-legged dog
instead of saying
i am a berliner or whatever kennedy was
saying when he said it it said
i love this three-legged dog it's so
stupid and fun
uh thanks for making me remember
the amazing champion thanks